Speaker 1: Donald Trump's ethics lawyer allegedly
told a witness to the January six Trump Riot
Committee to lie under oath. This is absolutely
unbelievable. CNN has an exclusive report. Trump's
former White House ethics lawyer told Kassidy
Hutchinson to give misleading testimony to
the January 6th committee, according to multiple
sources. Look at this. The January six committee
made a startling allegation on Monday, claiming
it had evidence that a Trump backed attorney
urged a key witness to mislead the
committee about details they recalled.
The committee declined to identify the people.
CNN has learned that Stefan Passantino, the top
ethics attorney in the Trump White House, is the
lawyer who allegedly advised his then client,
former White House aide Cassidy Hutchinson,
to tell the committee that she did not
recall details that she did recall. Sources
familiar with the committee's work tell CNN.
Trump's Save America PAC funded Passantino and
his law firm Elections LLC, including paying
for his representation of Hutchinson. Other
sources tell CNN the committee report notes
the lawyer did not tell his client who was paying
for the legal services. When asked about pressure
on Hutchinson after Monday's hearing, committee
member Representative Zoe Lofgren told CNN she
was advised to say she didn't recall something
when she did. So that's pretty serious stuff. The
episode is just one of several instances in which
the committee has accused members of Trump's orbit
of trying to obstruct the panel's investigation.
This is extraordinarily serious. If true,
if a lawyer were to tell a congressional witness
to lie under oath, it could potentially constitute
the crime of perjury or the related offense of
suborning of perjury or maybe subordination of
perjury, which is the act of inducing someone to
commit perjury. And it's important to note that
the specific legal consequences of that depend
on the details of the case the applicable law,
the circumstances, what you can prove, as
is often the case when it comes to perjury,
etc., etc.. Now, you and I, of course, recognize
the kind of oxymoronic nature of a Trump ethics
lawyer. I get that we're not even going to focus
in on that. But this is sort of like a third layer
of what is going on with the Trump rights, because
you have sort of at the top of the food chain,
as the case may be, at the top of the pyramid is
the riot itself and who was involved in inciting
and the planning of that riot? That's number
one. Number two is you have the witnesses
at the Trump Riot Committee hearings
and whether they told the truth or lied,
whether they were tampered with, etc.. The
third layer now is, were there other people
influencing the testimony of the witnesses at
the January six committee hearing about the
Trump riots and who incited those? So you've got
like Trump inciting the riot and then you've got
Cassidy Hutchinson testifying about what she saw
in terms of who was inciting or talking about or
trying to dissuade the rioters. And now we have
a third level, which is who influenced Cassidy
Hutchinson's testimony and potentially told
her to say she doesn't recall things that she
actually does recall about that top layer of the
pyramid. We now have three layers to this pyramid.
The fourth layer maybe is like the rioters
themselves. In some way it starts to get
extraordinarily complicated. But this is already
above and beyond anything that we have seen in
the history of the United States. Part of
the difference is in an era of records for
communication and text messages, an event that was
on camera and on and on, that makes it different
in terms of our ability to actually see and figure
out what went on. And that's understandable. But
there has never been anything like this in
American history. And so we are going to at
some point see if and when the Justice Department
decides to act on those criminal referrals that
have already been sent forward. And that applies
to Donald Trump, as we learned earlier this week,
John Eastman, the lawyer, and others. But there's
this whole other layer, which is what about all
of the perjury that is suspected among some of
the witnesses and then who got to them and was
there indeed witness tampering? One of the
things that was also alleged during maybe it
was the second to last or one of the kind of later
public hearings of the January six committee was
that there were individuals there were multiple
instances of individuals reaching out to witnesses
and allegedly trying to intimidate or tamper. I
don't believe we ever actually fully got to the
bottom of that. I don't think this example is the
full scope of that, and that's just another layer
that needs to be investigated. Unfortunately, the
January six committee is going to end because this
session of Congress is ending and then Republicans
are taking over. They don't want to look into the
riots. They want to look into stuff like the
genitalia of Hunter Biden and stuff like that.
So things are going to change dramatically,
but we will hopefully get to the bottom of
this component. And again, Trump ethics lawyer,
I don't know of any greater oxymoron than that.